uh
we are broadcasting this fighting
tournament globally so uh standards and
practices is going to need a written
transcript of everything you say when
you're fighting just so we can make sure
it's uh cleared for appropriate
audiences is that something we can do
sure okay great uh well so why don't you
just tell me everything you'll be saying
okay
um when i throw my
fireball i say
hot dukin hot chicken
okay what else when i uppercut i say
sure you can sure
you can
okay what else uh my hurricane kick i
say hi take check fruitcat
look at that fat
attack the fruity kid wow
wow you can't be saying attack the
fruity kid no i'm not saying attack the
fruity kid help me help you could you
could you please just spell it for me
t
t that's o
uh exclamation mark
oh it keeps going
there's a q nobody heard a q in there
so there's an exclamation point in the
middle of the word
it's an ancient japanese word so it's
really hard to spell with english
letters you don't know what you're
saying of course you don't know what
you're saying
you don't know what i do it's just
really
hard to spell you made a mistake you
said it once and you've been saying it
ever since to cover your ass
yes
okay that's fine i just think that's
going to be a bit of a problem because
if you don't know what it means for all
we know it means i hate the jews i don't
hate the jews luckily s p has sent over
a pre-approved list of things you could
say when you do your hurricane kick um
how's about this one my spinny kick will
kick you and hurt a lot i can't say that
i need to strike fear in my opponents
how about my fierce foot will attack
your ass
i don't think that'll ever fly um it's a
little blue how about um feel the wrath
of my little piggies making contact with
your put them no a what a what put them
it's yiddish do you hate the jews how
about uh
my hurricane of flesh will pound your
ass
okay what's with you in asses it's my
fighting style did you say fighting
style or lifestyle you know i said
fighting style which is a little
confusing you're always charming it up
with ken training rolling running
scruffing hair
nope how about this legal sent this over
your face if we're not close no i'm i'm
sticking
if you don't pick one of these
pre-approved fight statements we can't
let you in the tournament
i know you have a vendetta with sagat
you got to solve that
you want another go adam don't you give
him another scar
okay
i'll i'll take the poonam one okay good
choice boonam i like that
two u's in that word good for scrabble
if you're playing with a rabbi
it's official
take that to legal
and uh lay off the asses okay you're the
popular one
even though you look like the karate kid
your name sounds like a noise arnold
schwarzenegger would make if you poked
him
go live